after two years of fighting in Ethiopia
Warren parties have agreed to lay down
their arms that's all thanks to a peace
deal broken by the African Union the
conflict in the northern tigray region
has left thousands dead Millions
displaced and brought famine to the
region here's what we know about the
deal Ethiopia's government and
tigrainian authorities agree to a
orderly smooth and coordinated
disarmament I also agreed to Restoration
of Law and Order and restoration of
services but most importantly for the
people there in the region to get
unhindered access to humanitarian
supplies now many wonder if the peace
deal will hold we'll explore that in a
moment but first let's look at how we
got here
the signing of this peace deal has been
long awaited on Wednesday the Ethiopian
government and Regional forces of tigray
finally put ink to paper bringing to
rest a conflict that began in 2020
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of blood has been spilled property
destroyed enough
[Applause]
the conflict in tigray region began due
to tensions between prime minister ABI
Ahmed and the local government integral
Ethiopia was ruled for three decades by
The tigray People's Liberation Front or
tplf but when Ahmed came to power he
formed a coalition that left out tplf
members TPL have blamed him for
centralizing power Ahmed denied the
accusation
that resentment turned to revolt after
the government cut tplf's funding and
other disagreements piled up
both sides blame each other for the
two-year war that has raged and
displaced more than 2.6 million people
with hundreds of thousands of deaths on
both sides and hundreds of thousands
facing famine
a ceasefire was declared in March 2022
but it didn't last long and the War
Began again
people in tigray are welcoming the peace
deal but they are only cautiously
optimistic
I'm happy about the peace treaty
everyone is but we've been living under
siege and blockade for two years without
power internet and banking nothing has
been said about when these basic
services will return internet banking
no one knows how quickly changes will
come about or if the piece that has just
begun will last
for some more analysis on this I'm
joined Now by Adam cassia baby senior
advisor for Constitution and peace
building at International institutes for
democracy and electoral assistance in
The Hague the Netherlands so Sarah
welcome to the program an agreement has
been reached to seize hostilities does
that mean peace has returned to Ethiopia
um certainly not it's a necessary
measure but it's far from sufficient so
it is critical that they have gotten to
this stage but peace will require a lot
of complicated measures and it will take
years
it will take years
um but we are still trying to be
optimistic the last agreement did not
last how optimistic are we that this
peace deal will last
um well I think that the last one didn't
didn't last in the sense that they all
sides still maintain their strengths at
that particular moment and then
crucially it was a unilateral agreement
so they there was no deal as such each
side essentially made the announcement
announce the truth but this time it was
assigned under the two in a total ship
of the African Union with the over the
observance of the United Nations and the
United States and it got there's a lot
more actors involved and the military
situation on the ground also I think
dictates it so there is a sense of uh
superiority especially on the on the
federal side but there's also an
understanding that uh peace peace deal a
negotiated deal is necessary to end and
so it is different there's no guarantee
that it will stick but it's certainly
different and and I think more hopeful
okay now there were a lot of issues
misunderstandings here and there that
led to the war in the first place has
this deal resolved the issues that
caused the War
um no it does not resolve them but it
provides a framework for their
resolution
um so if you look at the the deal in
detail it provides for a lot of
negotiated outcomes for some of the key
issues including the the representation
of uh to grind in the center the kind of
interim Administration that has to be
established and crucially also for for
the resolution of the contested lands uh
between between uh between amhara and
antiquary regions
um and so it's an accessory as I said
but it's it's it's not sufficient it
provides a framework a necessary
framework and if the parties take
advantage of them
um I think they have the best chance to
arrive at the negotiated sustainable
solution that will not only end this war
but also but also crucially uh and
future Wars prevent future Wars as well
so what are the next steps to take after
striking this deal
a number of measures
um so there's a lot of agreement
prioritization of hostilities
establishment of an interim Arrangement
and that requires first the removal of
the tplf from the terrorist terrorism
designation which would hopefully happen
quickly because that is necessary for
formal deals formal negotiations to
happen
um and of course also process around
around a negotiation to solve the land
issue and others so there's a number of
a number of a number of measures and the
peace agreement I must say is quite
optimistic in terms of its timelines
um but I expect that given the
complications giving the the the
seriousness of the issues that will be
dealt with uh progress will be met but
the first step would be for in my
opinion to start the disarmament process
but also to remove the terrorism
designation so that all the other
measures can can proceed as as planned
we're talking about a war that raged on
for two years a lot of people people
have lost their loved ones that many
have been displaced I mean Minnie's
lives have just been
brought down massively how does Ethiopia
move on from this how does Ethiopia
reconcile with all of this
um I think that that's perhaps the the
million dollar question you're right has
been a brutal brutal War particularly on
the civilian population uh hundreds of
sounds hundreds of thousands of soldiers
and civilians uh have have died and most
importantly the propaganda the hate
speech and the animosity between the
grants and amhara and our first but
across the country has been has been
extremely extremely uh worry and so in
in that sense I think that the most
fundamental job will not will not just
be to silence the guns but also to
silence the propaganda and then start
essentially reversed gear and use
traditional traditional leaders
religious leaders and and public media
to promote a new sense of identity a new
sense of relationship and so it will be
difficult I think we've broken a lot of
Bones we've broken a lot of a lot of
mind
um but it will be necessary I think
sustainable peace will require it and
disregard the agreement already
anticipates a mechanism a transitional
Justice mechanism to lead to
reconciliation healing true selling and
also as necessary accountability and
then of course also as necessary
compensation and redress for for
individual victims and so uh you know
this is an outcome of animosity of
hatred of of decades and it will take
several years before it is it is
completely resolved
senior advisor for Constitution and
peace building at International
Institute for democracy and electoral
assistance in The Hague Netherlands
thank you very much for your time
thank you very much